تعهد نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني ملك
عقار بمواصله العمل لوقف الحرب بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وكان رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان قد عين عقار في هذا المنصب
ضمن حزمه قرارات تضمنت اعفاء نائبه السابق
الفريق محمد حمدان دادلو قائد الدعم
السريع من منصب نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وتعيين نائب ومساعدين للقائد العام للجيش
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف
يمكن قراءه التغييرات الجديده في الجيش
ومجلس السياده سيما تعيين عقار نائبا
لرئيس المجلس السيادي في هذا التوقيت وما
المواصفات التي اهلته للاختيار في هذا
المنصب
وما دلاله تجديد عقار موقفه الداعي لايقاف
الحرب
وتعهده بمواصله العمل على وضع حد لها وما
هي الاوراق التي يملكها للتاثير في هذا
الاتجاه
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تنعكس التعيينات
السياسيه والعسكريه الجديده وما قد يتبعها
من تفاعلات على المشهدين السياسي والعسكري
في السودان
[موسيقى]
تعهد عقار الذي يتولى رئاسه الحركه
الشعبيه لتحرير السودان شمال بمواصله
العمل على التواصل لوقت اطلاق النار ثم
ايقاف الحرب بشكل دائم اشار ايضا الى ان
العمل جار لاستكمال مسار التحول المدني
الديمقراطي على اساس مشاركه جميع
السودانيين من دون اقصاء
وخطب عقار قياده قوه الدعم السريع بقوله
انه لا بديل الاستقرار السودان الا عبر
جيش مهنيا واحد وموحد وان الحرب لا يوجد
فيها منتصر اضاف انه يرجو الجلوس للحوار
بعقل وقلب مفتوحين حسب تعبيره واضاف عقار
ان الجيش مؤسسه سودانيه عريقه قبل ان يقول
انه لا بديل للسلام الا للسلام ولا مدخل
للسلام الا من باب الحوار حسب تعبيره
تعيين عقار جاء ضمن حزمه قرارات اصدر رئيس
مجلس السياده والقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان
تضمنت قرارات بتعيين الفريق اول ركن شمس
الدين كباشي نائبا للقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه حسب بيان للجيش السوداني
وبحسب البيان ايضا فان القرار شمل تعيين
الفريق اول ركن ياسر عبد الرحمن حسن العطا
مساعدا للقائد العام للقوات المسلحه
والفريق بحري مهندس مستشار ابراهيم جابر
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من باريس محمد
نورسين الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
ومن الدوحه ضياء الدين بلال الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني
ونبدا معك سيد ضياء الدين عن الرسائل التي
حملتها هذه التغييرات اكان في قياده الجيش
او حتى بشكل اساسي تعيين ملك عقار نائبا
لرئيس مجلس السياده بعد اقاله محمد حمدان
داكلو
هذه القراءات جات في سياق مجموعه من
القرارات التي اتخذت من قبل الفريق
البرهان منها ما هو اقتصادي ومنه وما هو
سياسي ومنها ما هو عسكري فيبدو ان
الضغوطات العسكريه التي كانت ممارسه على
قياده الجيش وعلى الفريق البرهان قد خفت
كثيرا النتيجه بعد المتغيرات الميدانيه
فبالتالي هو ينتقل الان الى ما بعد هذه
العمليات ينظر الى ما بعد هذه العمليات
وربما يريد ترتيب الاوضاع
القادمه عبر هذه القرارات خاصه وان هنالك
انحصار كبير
لنشاط
للعمليات العسكريه من قبل الدعم السريع
اعتقد ان هذه الترتيبات هي الترتيبات
استباقيه لما يمكن ان تترتب عليه الاوضاع
ما بعد انتهاء هذه المعارك لكن هذه
الترتيبات تتضمن
اسماء عديده ولكل اسم ربما رساله معينه
اراد من خلالها البرهان ان يرسلها في اكثر
من اتجاه لو بدانا بمالك عقار لماذا الان
بعد 34 يوم من
اندلاع الاقتتال في السودان
قرر عبد الفتاح البرهان القيام بهذه
الخطوه واقاله محمد حمدان حميدتي مع كل
الجدل المثال حول هذه الخطوه قانونيا نعم
كانت هنالك كثير من المطالب من قبل الجهات
متعدده بان يتم اقاله
من منصبه ولكن لم تحدث هذه الاستجابه الا
متاخره واظن ان هذه الاستجابه مترتبه على
الاوضاع الميدانيه وربما كان هنالك
مسعى من قبل البرهان لفتح باب للمساومه
بالابقاء على حميتي في موقعه ولكن بعد
تصاعد العمليات العسكريه وبعد انحسار
قوه
ونيران الدعم السريع بدا يفكر في هذا
الخيار واعتقد انه خيار مالك على الدار
المؤشر الاساسي فيه ان مالك عقار من
الاعضاء الاساسيين في اتفاقيه جبى فهو
يريد البرهان عبر هذا الاختيار ان يقوي
الجبهه الداخليه وان يحرك القيادات
القيادات
الاتفاقيه السلام النحو مربع الانحياز
لرؤيته ولموقفه وتحريكه من ذلك المربع
الذي يلتزم الحياد قلت نقطه يعني انه كانه
ابقى الباب مواربا لمده 34 يوم
علما انه من اليوم الاول
اعتبره قوه متمرده واعلن
مواجهات مواجهته بالحرب وعدم قبول الحوار
معه كيف ترك الباب مواربا 34 يوم وهو منذ
اليوم الاول حاسم الموضوع بشكل كامل
هو لم يكن لم تكن هذه المعركه خيار
البرهان هذه المعركه كانت عباره عن مشروع
انقلابي
لحميتي وللدعم السريع للسيطره على السلطه
انا اسال عن موقف البرهان انا اسالك هو
منذ البدايه اعتبره متمر واعتبر ان لا
حوار معه فكيف يكون قد ترك الباب مواربا
للحوار كان هنالك كانت هنالك مساعي وكانت
هنالك مساعي مختلف الجهات
لفتح باب الحوار وفتح باب الحوار في جده
فبالتالي هو يعلم مواقف ذا الطبيعه عسكريه
ولكنه في نفس الوقت لا يتجاوز الجوانب
السياسيه الاخرى فهو يضع اختبار للجوانب
السياسيه حتى ولو كان الحيز المقدم من
قبله حيز ضيق متعلق بالابقاء على منصبه
الى ان تنجلي الاوضاع وربما كان البرهان
في ذلك الوقت تحت الضغط العسكري
القوي من قبل الدعم السريع فهو محاصر محاط
بقوات الدعم السريع في اماكن كثيره
دعنا هنا يعني نستمع الى وجهه النظر السيد
تورشين بهذه التعيينات وما الذي ما
المواصفات التي اهلت مالك عقارب برايك
لان يكون نائب لرئيس مجلس السياده بد لا
من محمد حمدان دقلو
في البدء التحيه لك ولكل الساده المشاهدين
الكرام وكذلك لضيفك الكريم انا في تقديري
اذا نظرنا الى تشكيله مجلس السياده او ما
تبقى من مجلس السياده الحالي اذا استثنينا
الى الجانب العسكري بنجد ان هنالك مالك
عقارب بالاضافه الى الطاهر حجر رئيس
التجمع حركات تحرير السودان ودكتور الهادي
ادريس رئيس
التحالف اول المجلس الانتقالي او اعتبارها
هي من اهم الحركات التي الان تشارك في
مجلس السياده فبالتالي مالك حرقار لديه
العديد من الميزات منها انه رجل لديه
تجربه
مستمره او منذ اندلاع او قيام الحركه
الشعبيه لتحرير السودان في مطلع ثمانينيات
القرن الماضي فضلا عن ذلك تولى مناصب
دستوريه مهمه منها والي ولايه النيل
الازرق هو جاء لهذا المنصب بنتيجه التعيين
وكذلك انتخاب في العمل 2010 ومن بعدها
تجددت الاحداث فضلا عن ذلك عضو مجلس
السياده فبالتالي انا في تقدير المؤهلات
التنظيميه والاداريه هو يتفوق على رصفاؤه
الاخرين فضلا عن ذلك هو ينتمي الى
المنطقتين باعتبار ان السودان في العرفه
السياسي او في الادويات السياسه في
السودان هنالك مناطق تسمى بالهامش والمركز
وهو
مالك عقار يعني
لا يتبنى التوصيفات
بشكل تام تلك التوصيفات التي تطلق على
الدعم السريع والموقف الحاسم لقائد الجيش
هو يدعو الى الحوار الى السلام يعني يبدو
وكانه متمايز عن عبد الفتاح البرهان
بطريقه التعاطي مع الاقتتال الجاري في
السودان
السيد مالك عقار الذي هو واخرون ممثلين في
حاكم اقليم دارفور من وهي من الحركات التي
وقعت ايضا على اتفاق الدول للسلام كانت
لديهم مبادره قبل اندلاء هذه المواجهات
بان يتم محاوله رعب الصدع وكذلك عوده
الاوضاع الى الى ما قبل التوترات التي
حدثت بعد اعاده انتشار وتواضع قوات الدعم
السريع في مروي بعض المناطق في الخرطوم
فبالتالي من الطبيعي جدا لهذا الرجل الذي
يتسم غالبا بالحكمه وهذه الحكمه في تقدير
نافعه نتيجه التجربه ونتيجه
سنوات طويله من النضال والعمل العسكري
باعتبار ان الخطاب الان ركز بان كل الحروب
التي بدات بما في ذلك حق الجنوب انتهت
بالملاحظات والتفاوض وربما في تقديري في
موقفه الذي الان يتسم بالمرونه نوعا ما
يسعى لان تكون هنالك جوله من المباحثات
ربما يستغل ايضا علاقته جيده مع دوله
الجنوب السودان وكذلك في المنطقه بشكل عام
حتى يمارس ضغطه على الدعم السريع ومن بعد
ان تكون هنالك مباحثات جاده والرساله انا
في تقدير ومهمه جدا التي اثرها بانه لا
يمكن ان يكون السودان مستقر ولا يمكن ان
تكون هنالك عمليه سياسيه حقيقيه وانتقال
المدني ديمقراطي من بعد الانتخابات حره
ونظيره في وجود اكثر من جيش وهذه رساله
انا في تقديري في بريد الدعم السريع وفي
البريد الحركات المسلحه التي وقعت على
اتفاق الجبل السلام وكذلك الذي لم توقع
بالرغم من ان البرهان في تقدير هذه الخطوه
ربما ايضا يرغب في ان تكون هنالك مباحثات
وهنالك تسويه سياسيه لكن هذه التسويه
السياسيه ينبغي ان تكون في اطار يتم دمج
قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش السوداني في
غايه زمني ربما اقل من زمن الذي تم طرحه
من قبله واللي هي فتره العميل وهذا ايضا
يؤكد بان هل هنالك الان متغيرات تمت او
عمليات عسكريه نوعيه استهدفت قيادات الدعم
السريع وجعلت المشهد السياسي الان مواتي
لاحداث هذه التغييرات المهمه جدا في عمليه
المياه باعتبار ان الان المعادله على ارض
الميدان حتى نكون اكثر موضوعيا الجيش لن
يستطيع انه تحقيق النصر لانه هنالك تباين
كبير جدا بين الاستراتيجيه التي تتبناها
القوات المسلحه والطبيعه التدريبة وحملها
وكذلك اسلحتها
واستراتيجيه حرب العصابات والحرب الخاطفه
التي تتبناها مليشه الدعم السريع اعود
اليك الدين فيما يتعلق بهذه التعيينات
باختصار اود ان اسال عن الاسس القانونيه
التي استند اليها البريه البرهان في تعيين
نائب لرئيس مجلس سياده اساسا هل هذا
الموقع موجود دستوريا اقله في المرحله
الانتقاليه وعلى اي اساس يتخذ القرار
منفردا من دون العوده الى مجلس السياده
ككل كما كان يقول ياسر العطا
الذي اعتبر ان
حماتي يجب ان يجتمع مجلس السياده برمته
ربما الان الظرف هو ظرف طوارئ لا اعتقد ان
هنالك قانون يحكم الان القانون الاساسي
الذي يحكم المعادلات داخل السودان هو
قانون الصراع العسكري فبالتالي ربما ارتجع
لهذا الخيار من باب الطوارئ بان هنالك
طوارئ تقتضي ذلك وخاصه ان الموقع نحن نسال
قانونا يعني هل هل اعلن البرهان حاله
طوارئ حتى يكون قراره مبنيا على حاله
الطوارئ حاله الطوارئ هي الا ان تعلن عن
نفسها عبر هذا الاقتتار الذي يتم في اماكن
كثيره في السودان ويتم بالقرب من القياده
ويتم في اماكن كثيره فبالتالي هذه الحاله
حاله
تعبر عن نفسها عبر عبر هذا السياق القتال
القائم ولكن اعتقد ان الجوانب السياسيه هي
المقدمه في هذا الاحتبار اكثر من الجوانب
القانونيه ينظر البرهان الى الجوانب
السياسيه يريد ان يقوي يعني افهم منك منك
انه لا اساس قانوني يعني حتى لا ندخل
كثيرا في في هذا ليس هناك اساس قانوني حتى
حتى حتى اختيار منصب النائب النائب المجلس
السيادي الذي ذكرتها لم تكن موجوده في
الوثيقه الدستوريه ولكن
تمزق بها عبر الاجتماعات الخاصه بمجلس
السياده وربما كان هنالك اشكال قانوني في
هذا الامر لا اعتقد ان الجدل القانوني
الان هو له الصوت العالي في هذه في هذه
الحاله السودانيه الحاله العسكريه والحاله
السياسيه المعقده اعتقد ان الاعتبارات كما
قلت قبل قليل الاختبارات السياسيه الان
مقدم على الاختبارات قانونيه لان البلاد
الان في حاله الطوارئ تخبر عن نفسها عبر
هذا الصراع الدامي الذي يدور داخل الخرطوم
طيب سيد تورشين لو انتقلنا الى التعيينات
العسكريه المتعلقه
نائب قائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ومساعدين اخرين له
ايضا ما هي قراءتك في هذا المشهد العسكري
الان
والمشهد العسكري به العديد من التقاطعات
وكذلك تسوده حاله من الرقه والضبابيه
باعتبار ان في في الغرفه السياسيه او
العرفه العسكري بالاحرف السودان دائما ما
يكون القائد العام للقوات المسلحه هو رئيس
هيئه الاركان والغاز الاعلى هو رئيس
الجمهوري او رئيس مجلس الوزراء في الانظمه
البرلمانيه لكن عندما حدث التغيير في 2019
البرهان النص هو نفسه هو القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه وفقا للتراتبيه العسكريه
وكذلك مضوا بانه عضو كذلك رئيس مجلس
السياده
والمكون العسكري للاخرين من المكونه
العسكري كشمس الدين كباشي وكذلك العطاء
وابراهيم جابر لكن انا في تقديره نتيجه
للظروف العسكريه المهمه جدا وربما البرهان
بهذه الخطوه يريد ان يمنح جنرال شمس الدين
مزيد من الصلاحيات حتى يتفرق هو لاداره
المجلس السياده او العمل السياسي وان
يتفرق كباش لاداره المؤسسه العسكريه
واحكام السيطره عليها باعتبار ان هذه
المعارك ربما تطول بالتالي بحاجه الى غيار
متفرغه لديها قدره على التواصل وكذلك
لديها قدره على اداره هذه العمليات ومعروف
معلوم ان شخصيه شمس الدين كباش هي لديها
قدرات في هذا المجال ومنذ الوهله الاولى
ومنذ الصوره الاولى كان التي صدرت من
القياده العامه للجيش اظهرت شمس الدين
كباشي وهو قاعد هذه العمليات
كثيرا في هذه الخطوه بل انه حاول انه ياطر
لمنهج جديد او لواقع جديد في اداره
المؤسسه العسكريه وربما هذا ايضا يحدث
رفقه فيما بعد في استكمال المسار السياسي
او استكمال الفتره الانتقاليه باعتبار انه
وجود عدد كبير جدا من الخيارات العسكريه
في هذه الظروف سيعقد تماما عمليه اداره
المؤسسه
اللثه انه لم تظهر يعني الشخصيات جديده
على المشهد في هذه التعيينات وهنا اسالك
سيد ضياء الدين
كيف قرات
التعيينات العسكريه كان شمس الدين الكباشي
او ياسر العطاء
او المستشار ابراهيم يعني كيف
فهمت هذه الرساله من قائد الجيش اعتقد ان
ذلك جزء من ترتيباتها القادمه ترتيبات
الفتره القادمه وخاصه وان هنالك حديث عبر
الملفات الحوار حول اصلاح القوات المسلحه
بان تكون قياده الجيش منفصله عن العمل
التنفيذي وهذا ما كان يتم السعي للوصول
اليه عبر الاتفاقيه الايطاليه وبالتالي
يبدو ان البرهان يريد ان يرسل رساله بانه
ملتزم باخراج القيادات العسكريه من داخل
الكبينه
مجلس المجلس السيادي
والاحتفاظ بهم داخل المؤسسه العسكريه لان
وجودهم وفقا للاتفاقيه الايطاليه الاتفاق
الايطالي ما كان له ان يستمر فبالتالي هو
يريد ان يحفظ لهم حق الوجود داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه وان لا يتم حالتهم البعض يرى هنا
سيد ضياء الدين وباختصار ايضا يرى بان هذا
تاكيد وتثبيت للقياده الحاليه
وتاكيد على عدم القيام باي مراجعه لما
يعتبر مثلا من قبل البعض اخطاء بتمكين
الدعم السريع في العاصمه وفي المراكز
العسكريه وبالتالي هذا تاكيد على النهج
السابق من دون اي مراجعه او اي اعتذار عن
الاخطاء هذه تساؤلات مرحله الى هذه
التساؤلات مرحله للفتره القادمه وليست
وليس الان موضع لتناوله خاصه العمليات لا
تزال قائمه وان هنالك قتال فبالتالي لا
اعتقد ان المسائله حول ما حدث في السابق
ستقول حاضره الان ربما تكون حاضره في اج
المستقبل ولكن في الراهن الان اعتقد انه
يريد ان يقوي الجانب العسكري ويريد ان
يهيئ الوضع السياسي لما بعد انتهاء الحرب
وارسال رساله للمجتمع الدولي بانه حريص
على عوده كل القيادات التي كانت في المجلس
السيادي الى الى السكنات العسكريه ستورشين
قراءتك ايضا وباختصار
لهذا المشهد وكيف لهذه التعيينات ان تنعكس
على الواقع العسكري
والمشهد عموما في السودان
انا في تقديري بتعيين مالك عقار في مثل
هذا الموسم المهم يبدو ان الجيش يعتمد
مقاربه الحوار بحيث انه يمكن ان هذا
الحوار يحدث اقتراب مهم جدا ومن شانه هو
ان يعود بالعمليه السياسيه الى الى مسارها
الطبيعي وكذلك المضي قدما في استكمال ما
تبقى من الفتره الانتقاليه وربما ذلك ايضا
هو طرح للمبادره السعوديه او غيرها لكن
انا في تقديري هل يمكن ان تستمر الاوضاع
بهذه الوضعيه التي بين الجيش والدعم
السريع كما كان ام هنالك تصورات مرتبطه
بدمج سريع متصورات مرتبطه باحاله قيادات
عسكريه بما في ذلك البرهان وغيره من
التقاعد نتيجه المبدا التنحي ربما تتطرحه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه باعتبار ان هذا هو
المبدا الذي يمكن ان يكون مخرج اما
الاتجاه الاخر اما ان يكون هنالك انتصار
حاسم في ارض المعركه وبالتالي يتم تعزيز
هذه الانتصارات على طاوله التفاوض فانا في
تقدير الخيارين هم الان ربما هم الاغرب
لكن انا ارجع خيارات التفاوض باعتبار ان
الحزم العسكري الذي يكون سهلا عفوا سيد
تورشين اذا اردنا ان ايضا ان نتحدث عن
الظروف التي احاطت الظروف العسكريه على
الارض لابد انك تبعت ما ذكرته الخارجيه
السودانيه من الاعتداء على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه في في الخرطوم واتهام الدعم
السريع بذلك الى اي مدى
لهذا التوقيت علاقه بما بما حصل لتلك
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والاعتداء الملاحظه هو كل الدول التي تم
الاعتداء عليها هي ذات موقف اقرب
للحكومه او للجيش السوداني باستثناء يعني
بعض الدول في تقديري الاعتداء على
الدبلوماسيه الاعتداء على الاعتداء على
المساجد هذا بمثابه افلا في تقدير الدعم
السرير ربما بهذه الخطوات يهيئ المجتمع
الدولي بان هنالك اعتداء ودائما التقارير
التي تخرج بان هناك اعتداء من طرف دون
تحديد الدعم السريع وهذا من شانه ايضا
يحاول ان يمنح شرعيه لمجلس الامن الدولي
وكذلك للدول العظمى في مجلس الامن الدوله
ان تتحرك وفقا لقطاء سواء كان الفصل
السابع عن طريق تدخل عسكري او عن طريق
باعفات للمراقبه فعلا وما الى ذلك انا في
تقدير الدعم يمضي في هذا الاتجاه بهذه
الممارسات او بهذا السلوك باعتبار انه لا
مبررا
السياسي السوداني من باريس وشكرا
لضياء الدين بلال كان معنا من الدوحه
انتهت حلقتنا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]